humans invented the electronic
calculator 80 years ago since then the
world of computing has witnessed seismic
advancements
the past few years in information
processing have especially been
transformational
what were once thought of as science
fiction fantasies are now technological
realities
classical computing has become more
exponentially faster and more capable
and are enabling devices smaller and
more adaptable
we are beginning to evolve beyond
classical computing into a new data era
called quantum computing
it is envisioned that quantum computing
will accelerate us into the future by
impacting the landscape of artificial
intelligence and data analytics
the quantum computing power and speed
will help us solve some of the biggest
and most complex challenges we face
quantum technology has been quickly
approaching mainstream adoption
several financial companies have
recently announced that they could soon
introduce quantum algorithms to price
financial instruments
industry experts anticipate that quantum
will form a one trillion dollar industry
in the decades ahead
to understand what's going on it's
useful to take a step back and examine
what exactly it is that computers do
let's start with today's digital
technology
at its core the digital computer is an
arithmetic machine
it made performing mathematical
calculations cheap and its impact on
society has been immense
advances in both hardware and software
have made possible the application of
all sorts of computing to products and
services
today's cars dishwashers and boilers all
have some kind of computer embedded in
them and that's before we even get to
smartphones and the internet
without computers we would never have
reached the moon or put satellites in
orbit
but there is a problem with classical
computers
they use binary signals that are
measured in bits
those famous ones and zeros of code
this means that the more complicated the
code the more processing power is
required and the longer the processing
takes to achieve a specific
computational objective there are many
tasks that traditional computing devices
struggle with even when the task is
dispersed across millions of machines
a particular problem they struggle with
is a category of calculation called
combinatorics
these calculations involve finding an
arrangement of items that optimizes some
goal
as the number of items grows the number
of possible arrangements grows
exponentially
to find the best arrangement today's
classical computers basically have to
iterate through each permutation to find
an optimal solution
in many cases this can require an
enormous number of calculations
and this is where quantum computers come
in quantum computers are based on a
completely different model of how the
world works
quantum computers use atomic quantum
states to run computation
data is held in qubits which can also be
set to one of two values
a qubit can be any two level quantum
system such as a spin and a magnetic
field or a single photon
zero and one are the system's possible
states like the photons horizontal or
vertical polarization
in the quantum world the qubit doesn't
have to be just one of those it can be
in any proportions of both states at
once
this is called superposition
but as soon as you test its value for
example by sending the photon through a
filter it has to decide to be either
vertically or horizontally polarized
so as long as it is unobserved the qubit
is in a superposition of probabilities
for zero and one and you can't predict
which it will be
but the instant you measure it it
collapses into one of the definite
states
superposition is a quantum computer's
superpower
classical computer's bits can be in one
of two to the power of four different
configurations at a time
that's 16 possible combinations out of
which you can use just one
four qubits in superposition however can
be in all of those 16 combinations at
once
this number grows exponentially with
each extra qubit another surprising
property of the quantum computers is the
entanglement effect
what this means is that the data held in
qubits is affected by data held in other
qubits instantaneously no matter how far
they are apart
when measuring just one entangled qubit
you can directly deduce properties of
its partners without having to look
from a computing perspective this
implies that data is recorded and stored
in a different way through non-binary
qubits of information rather than binary
bits reflecting the multiplicity of
states in the quantum world
this multiplicity can enable faster and
lower cost calculation for combinatoric
arithmetic and is a true game changer
quantum computers can do many of the
things that classical computers can
however in addition they do one big
thing classical computers cannot perform
combinatorics calculations quickly
google's quantum computer for example
has recently completed a calculation in
less than four minutes that would take
the world's most powerful classical
computer 10 000 years to complete
the following five domains will be
disrupted by the quantum computers
first artificial intelligence quantum
computing opens up new opportunities in
ai which often involves the combinatoric
processing of very large quantities of
data in order to make better predictions
and decisions
a growing research field in quantum
machine learning identifies ways that
quantum algorithms can enable faster ai
the current limitations on the
technology and software make quantum
artificial general intelligence a fairly
remote possibility but it certainly
makes thinking machines more than a
subject for science fiction
second drug discovery
chemical and biological engineering
involve the discovery and manipulation
of molecules
doing so involves the motion and
interaction of subatomic particles
in other words it involves quantum
mechanics
as molecules get more complex the number
of possible configurations grows
exponentially
it becomes a combinatoric's calculation
suitable for a quantum computer
with the emerging feasibility of quantum
simulations which helps predict the
properties of new molecules engineers
will be able to consider molecule
configurations that would otherwise be
challenging to model
this ability means that quantum
computers will play an important role in
accelerating current efforts in
materials discovery and drug development
third cyber security
combinatorics have been central to
encryption for over a thousand years
alcohol's eighth century book of
cryptographic messages looked at
permutations and combinations of words
today's encryption is still built on
combinatorics emphasizing the assumption
that combinatoric calculations are
essentially unmanageable
with quantum computing however cracking
encryption becomes much easier which
poses a threat to data security
a new industry is growing that helps
companies prepare for upcoming
vulnerabilities in their cyber security
fourth complex manufacturing
quantum computers can be used in taking
large manufacturing data sets on
operational failures and translating
them to combinatoric challenges that can
identify which part of a complex
manufacturing process contributed to
incidents of product failure
for products like microchips where this
production process can have thousands of
steps quantum can help reduce costly
failures
fifth financial services
finance was one of the earliest domains
to embrace big data
and much of the science behind the
pricing of complex assets such as stock
options involves combinatoric
calculation
when financial firms price derivatives
they usually apply a highly compute
intensive calculation known as a monte
carlo simulation which makes projections
based on simulated market movements
computing speed has long been a source
of advantage in financial markets where
hedge funds build complex infrastructure
to get millisecond advantages in getting
price information
quantum computing will definitely help
financial industry to make the next big
leap forward
we are entering a fascinating period in
the development of quantum computers
where a lot of industries will be
disrupted in the years to come
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell